it is our pleasure today to hear from
colin raffle
um so colin is an assistant professor
in computer science at the university of
north carolina in chapel hill colin is
also a faculty researcher at hugging
face
and um well maybe uh you might know him
from
the celebrated t5 work um that that he
did um he's really worked on all kinds
of things related to sequence modeling
generalization and memorization
uh
learning from limited data uh
semi-supervised unsupervised transfer
learning so
i'm sure he's gonna have lots of
interesting things to share with us
today so
um
thanks so much for joining us
uh thanks a lot for the introduction um
and i assume everyone can see my slides
or else
holler if there's a problem
um and i i will be taking questions at
two very clear breaks in this talk uh
and so if you do have questions feel
free i think one of the the tas is is
fielding them and uh and will relay them
back to me
during the talk so yeah thanks again for
having me i'm going to be talking about
language modeling and language models
something that i've worked on quite a
bit recently and which i think is of
interest to a meta learning class so let
me try to explain why
so
just to get everyone on the same page
one of the
most common ways that people use
language models is kind of diagrammed on
the screen here
and
what we do is we typically take a bunch
of unlabeled text data and we apply
something called we call like a
self-supervised or an unsupervised
objective and what that means is that
without actually having to hand label
any data i can just kind of transform my
data in some way that there's something
interesting to predict from it so here
is an example self-supervised objective
where you're going to be training the
model to fill in the blanks so we take
this chunk of text shown in green
and we drop out some words that are that
now have uh been replaced by blanks
and then in the yellow you can see all
the missing words and we're just going
to train the model to fill in those
missing words and so this process again
doesn't require any human labeling as
long as we have unlabeled text data we
can apply this
unsupervised pre-training step the
self-supervised objective
and it turns out that if you do this
self-supervised training as a first step
before you actually train the model to
do something useful it's incredibly
helpful so this pre-training step
it tends to make it so that the model
converges faster with less labeled data
to a better performance on a given task
that you actually care about we usually
call these tasks that we actually care
about downstream tasks and
we say that we fine-tune the pre-trained
model on the downstream task so you can
see on the right here we're going to be
fine-tuning on let's say a
sentiment analysis task where we feed
the model in a movie review and train
the model to predict whether the movie
review is positive or negative and
typically we have label data in this
setting
but it allows us to adapt the
pre-trained model to some sort of
important downstream task
and this
setup is what we typically call transfer
learning i i will be describing other
ways that people use language models but
it it's
not an exaggeration to say that this is
one of the most important applications
of language models at least in recent
years
and so to kind of
illustrate that
and why that's true
here's a plot over time of the exact
match score on the squad reading
comprehension benchmark so this is a
task where the model is fed a paragraph
and then it's asked a question about the
paragraph and it has to extract the
answer from the paragraph it's what we
call i would call reading comprehension
and you can see that like on most
benchmarks the performance of different
models has
gotten better and better over time which
is just you know great and exciting but
i would delineate kind of these results
into two categories the categories
before people were using a lot of
transfer learning at least in the
paradigm that i described earlier
and the and models that use really an
extensive amount of
transfer learning as shown on the right
here and you can see there ended up
being a huge boost in performance when
we shifted to this pre-train the full
model and then fine-tuned the full model
paradigm
and the other thing that has made
language models particularly useful
recently is scale
and as many of you probably have heard
or know
many of the language models that we
train today just seem to keep getting
better when we make them bigger and
train them on more text data so this
plot here shows two axes one the size of
the model in blue and in red the glue
score which is the score on a popular
kind of meta benchmark of nlp tasks and
as with squad the performance has gone
up over time but notably the size of the
models that have gotten state-of-the-art
performance has also increased pretty
dramatically over time
and
[Music]
there are some issues and questions
around this that i'll describe much
later but
in general it's a pretty useful property
of a method that the performance tends
to get better when you make the model
bigger and train it on more data because
it's very easy to get this unlabeled
unstructured text data that we apply the
self-supervised objective to
so this this is another factor that has
made language models a very powerful and
uh popular
choice in natural language processing
recently
so one particular language model that i
helped developed a couple years ago is
called t5 and one of the things that
distinguishes t5 from
other similar models is that we actually
use it to tackle a extremely diverse
collection of downstream tasks and
specifically
you can think of t5 as having like a
natural language interface where you
feed it some data and you tell it via a
task prefix what you want the model to
do with that data so for example we want
the model to translate from english to
german we want the model to determine
whether a sentence is acceptable that
comes from the cola benchmark the corpus
of linguistic acceptability
and you can see that t5 specifically
casts not only the input as a text field
but also the output as a text field so
if we're doing a classification task
where for example we're classifying
whether text is acceptable or not we
actually train the model to output the
text not acceptable or if we're doing a
regression task by showing yellow here
we actually train the model to output a
string representation of the floating
point number
and by applying this kind of
text-to-text framework to a very a
wide variety of tasks we can take the
same model and apply it to lots of tasks
and ultimately achieve very good
performance on all of these tasks
so since you're in a meta learning class
this diagram might look a little bit
familiar to you i guess i should say the
last diagram might look familiar to you
but certainly this diagram should look
familiar to you
and this diagram from the mammal paper
is kind of
summarizing the key the key goal of
metal learning which is that we should
find a model a set of parameters
that can be rapidly adapted to many many
diverse downstream tasks hopefully with
as little data as possible
and indeed uh via the t5 model and many
other models we've actually shown that
the the pre-trained t5 model can be
rapidly adapted to a white very wide
variety of downstream tasks with
relatively little labeled data so in
effect
we have kind of accidentally been doing
meta learning in the sense that just by
doing simple self-supervised
pre-training we've ended up with a model
that can be rapidly adapted to lots of
tasks
and so what i'm going to try to answer
in this lecture is
why does this language modeling approach
effectively result in meta learning uh
you know we're not using any of the
machinery of metal metal learning right
we're just kind of training a model on
an objective that seems to be useful and
then kind of by accident it's very
readily adaptable to lots and lots of
diverse tasks so so why is that true why
is language modeling such a useful
objective despite its simplicity
and the the reasons that i'll kind of
the reasons that i'll try to provide
today
are shown on the screen here and have
been validated through various papers
that i'll be covering in detail
and so the the kind of if i had to
postulate why this is true i would say
it seems that language modeling teaches
models first word meaning syntax and
grammar kind of like the basics of
language
language modeling also seems to teach
models general knowledge about the world
like facts and trivia and even memorized
information
and then finally uh most recently what's
gotten people very excited is that it
seems that language modeling kind of
accidentally teaches language models how
to perform tasks so even with virtually
basically no additional training
language models seem to be able to
perform a wide variety of tasks in some
cases which is quite interesting
so i'll try to give you some
demonstrations of these different
properties try to explain why they might
happen
and and and use that to answer this
larger question of why language modeling
is
it seems to be an effective way to do to
produce a meta learner
so first i'll focus on this this first
facet
and to do that i'm actually going to go
back even further into the history of of
models for nlp and describe word vectors
so for those of you who worked on nlp
before the era of bert and other
pre-trained models you probably
encountered word vectors
and the idea and the goal of a word
vector is to associate each word in the
vocabulary with a single fixed length
vector of continuous values so you can
think of it a vector in some you know d
dimensional space
and you want these vectors to reflect
some
amount of meaning about the word that
they represent and i'll describe what i
mean by meaning in a second
but first i'll just say that the
the objective that we use actually
is you can think of it kind of like a
self-supervised objective
that's not so dissimilar to the way that
we train language models now
we might have a chunk of text unlabeled
unstructured text shown on the top here
the dog and cat 8 pot pie
and the way that word vectors one way
that word vectors are trained shown on
the screen here
is
that we model the probability of the
word eight given the word cat
as soft max applied to a
matrix v
that comprises all of the word vectors
dot product of that matrix times a
different word vector for this kind of
pivot word the center word cat w cat and
then we index this soft max at the eight
location
so i i'm using cat and eight as indices
here i hope people are comfortable with
that
but
to sort of recap we're taking a center
word like cat and for each word within a
window around cat we're saying that the
probability of that word given cat
is computed by taking the a word vector
for cat computing its dot product
against the
entire collection of word vectors that
we're learning
and computing the softmax of that and
that gives us the probability of that
particular word and so over we're
basically optimizing both v and w cat in
order to maximize the probability
of words that co-occur in our in our
pre-training corpus
this particular word vector model is
called a skip gram word vector model
there are other ways of learning word
vectors and this is by no means the the
best
per se but it is an effective one and
hopefully is a pretty intuitive and easy
to understand
so if we do this word vector
pre-training
then we end up with some interesting and
useful characteristics for our word
vectors and these examples are actually
taken from a different word vector model
that's a little it takes a little more
explanation so i'm not going to describe
it here but it's called glove
uh
skip gram word vector bottles have
similar properties it's just that this
one had some nice diagrams that i stole
and the first is that word vectors seem
to capture word similarity so if you
take for example the word vector for the
word frog
and you find all of the the most similar
word vectors according to their let's
say their cosine similarity
then the words that you end up with are
shown in the list and the top left so
frog is most similar to frogs okay so
plurals and singles singular uh forms of
nouns are similar that's great but frog
is also similar to toad victoria
leptodec philiday
these additional scientific looking
words are the names of different
basically the names of different frog
species um it's also similar to lizard
for example so you can tell that the
model kind of knows that a frog is some
kind of uh uh
is
similar like the word frog is similar to
more specific descriptions of frogs and
also animals that are similar to frogs
like toads and lizards so that's quite
interesting right again all of this sort
of fell out of a simple self-supervised
objective that just said that words that
co-occur
sorry words that uh are
surrounded by similar words should have
a similar representation so you might
imagine like a sentence the frog hopped
across the road and the toad hopped
across the road right so frog and toad
appear in similar context there
therefore their word vectors should be
similar and therefore uh we end up with
this property that toad is essentially
the most similar singular noun to frog
in according to our word vectors
the other property that people like to
point to in word vectors is that the
relationship between different word
vectors
that have a certain
the the sort of
uh spatial relationship between word
vectors that have some particular
linguistic relationship is very similar
so for example the displacement between
the word vector for strong and the word
vector for stronger is similar to the
displacement between the word vector for
loud and the word louder uh so you can
see that these uh kind of if you take an
adjective and you convert it to a
comparative adjective and then into and
from there convert it into an uh
kind of the
the most superlative form of the
adjective you end up with similar
displacements so this space of word
vectors ends up having a lot of very
interesting and useful structure and you
can imagine that feeding these word
vectors into a downstream model instead
of let's say one hot vectors that
represent word identity
would imbue the model with a lot of
knowledge about the meaning and
relationship of different words and
again all of this just falls out of the
intuitive notion that if two words
appear in similar contexts they might
mean similar things
or at least their vectors should be
similar
so
after word vectors came
a model called elmo
and the motivation for elmo is that when
we create a representation of the given
word
we actually probably want to take into
consideration not just that all of the
context that the word appeared in during
pre-training but the specific context
that that specific word appears in a
particular sentence so for example
well let me just wait till the next
slide to give an example first i'll
describe the model
so the ma the difference between
the elmo model and a word vector model
is rather than having a specific fixed
set of word vectors we're actually going
to feed our sentence into a model that
will represent the
words in that sentence with different
vectors on a sentence by sentence basis
and the way that elmo specifically does
that is by taking two
r and n's one going in the forward
direction one going in the backwards
direction
and feeding the sentence into the two r
and n's and using the hidden states of
those rnns as the vector representation
for each word
and during pre-training the objective
used to train the model is basically a
next step prediction objective that goes
in the forward and backward direction so
the forward lstm the forward
neural network tries to predict the word
cat from the prefix the dog and
the others are missing but there are
actually no i think i didn't have the in
my example sentence but at any rate the
the forward lstm tries to predict cat
given the history and the backwards lstm
tries to predict cat from what came
after it so this is kind of this auto
regressive kind of next step prediction
style language model pre-training is
usually what people mean when they just
say language model pre-training but the
key distinction here for elmo is that it
happens in a both a forward and a
backwards direction
and because a given word can have a
different representation
based on the sentence it appears in you
get this very nice property that the
word vectors become contextualized is
what people say so for example with
glove word vectors the ones that i
showed the frog example earlier
a given word vector only has one
representation it doesn't matter where
the word appears in a given chunk of
text it always produces exactly the same
representation and so if you do this
nearest neighbor thing that we described
earlier where we take a word like play
and find the nearest neighbors you can
see that playing game games played
players plays player play football
multiplayer are are the nearest words
and you can see that these words
actually
are kind of semantically different in
some cases right so playing is a is a
verb a player is a noun that that maybe
is a a part of a game
but there's also other forms of the word
play that might appear for example like
a theatrical play
and and you can see that there this
model lmo which they're denoting the by
lm the bi-directional language model
ends up producing a
uh contextualized representation of play
that finds that can be used to find
similar uses of the word play so for
example the nearest neighbor for play in
the first example
is is shown in in the second row there
and for the second example is the is the
on the bottom row and you can see that
in for example in the bottom row it's
talking about a broadway play
and the nearest neighbor the nearest
contextualized word representation
neighbor is from a chunk of text talking
about again a theatrical play
so
again by using uh maybe slightly more
intricate
architecture and but still a very simple
self-supervised objective we can get
this nice ability that the word vectors
become contextualized
and hopefully it's intuitive to see why
why that's true
now the the last model that i'll talk
about in terms of explaining how
language models learn uh you know word
meaning grammar syntax etc is the bert
model which i've made a very simple
schematic of here because i won't be
going into a ton of detail about it but
in bert we feed our sentence the dog and
cat eight pot pie
and instead of training the model to
predict what comes next after a prefix
or what came before
after according to a suffix
we actually just going to take random
words from the input text and
replace them with a mask token which
i've denoted by these this m surrounded
by less than or greater than
and in bert
the goal of the self-supervised
pre-training objective is to predict the
masked out words from the words that
aren't masked out right so if you saw
the sentence dog in blank ate pot pie
and you needed to fill in that blank
maybe you'd fill it in with cat maybe
you'd fill it in with
boy i don't know but either way you
would hope to be able to figure out the
identity of that word from its
surrounding context and so you can think
of this uh
as probabilistically modeling
[Music]
the word cat according to the equation
on the bottom there basically just that
we're predicting cat from the
surrounding context
and a key architectural innovation of
bert
is that rather than using a recurrent
neural network like elmo it uses a
a layer type that we call self-attention
and again i'm not going to go into a ton
of detail about self-attention
except to say that what self-attention
allows the model to do is refer back to
arbitrary input positions when
generating a new representation for a
given position
so and i've kind of denoted that with
these lines these lines connecting the
different nodes in the yellow model here
but you can think of it as as you know
if i need to predict
the
uh
if if i need to fill in a missing word
then maybe it's most valuable for me to
look at another specific word or another
few words
because you know maybe it's a pronoun
and i need to figure out what word the
pronoun refers to
or something like that
and and it turns out that this form of
self-attention is a much more efficient
way of bridging dependencies in
sequential data than a recurrent neural
network which has to store all of the
information about the sequence in its
hidden state
and so one type of analysis you can do
with self-detention models or attention
models in general is basically looking
at what
c position in the input the model is
attending to the most when it generates
the representation for a particular
entry in the output sequence
and so
this nice paper analyzed
many of the self-attention patterns in
bert to try to see what kind of things
bert was attending to when generating
representation for a particular word and
interestingly if you just look at the
the
word or words that the model is most
attending to
at a given position
and treat that as a classifier to try to
identify
things like uh
which word does a pronoun refer to for
example or
or you know
which verb does
sorry which noun does a verb apply to
and so on you actually get very high
accuracy and you can see some
illustrations of this here
so this to me suggests that bert has
some has learned some knowledge about
grammar and structure and syntax of
language in the sense that uh it it has
figured out without any explicit
supervision
that when it's generating the
representation for a particular word
there are specific words with specific
relationships that are most useful for
predicting that particular word
and and that maybe gives it this kind of
knowledge which is quite interesting and
useful and again it falls out of a
pretty simple self-supervised objective
so hopefully that convinces you that
various types of language models or
things that are used for modeling
language
teach the model
word meaning syntax and grammar before
going on to the next bit i'll ask if
there are any questions about what i
just said
cool so i think i'll go ahead and uh
carry on then
so
the next
thing that i mentioned that language
modeling seems to teach language models
is world knowledge and when i say world
knowledge i
i kind of mean a broad set of things but
uh to try to be a little more specific i
i'm talking about kind of learning facts
about the world and some of these might
be you know trivia facts some of them
might be very very specific facts some
of them might be you know general
purpose
things properties of of well-known
things
to give you a very specific example uh
shown on the screen here uh for example
maybe knowing the birthplace of dante
you know this is a very famous person
and uh their birthplace might be a
well-known fact about the world
and
typically in the past when people have
wanted to store this kind of
relationship
a common structure to use as a knowledge
graph uh knowledge graph is a way of
storing relationships between different
entities like dante and florence so you
might say that uh dante has the born in
relationship with florence meaning that
dante was born in florence
and
a knowledge graph is a very useful way
of representing these kinds of
relationships but they typically require
at least some amount of uh construction
by hand you know and and there are some
incredible knowledge crafts out there in
the world that that involve a lot of
human labor to uh to create
but what people have started to notice
about language models is that language
models themselves kind of build an
implicit knowledge graph and so for
example if we train a language model
like elmo or bert
and we feed the language model with a
sentence like shown here dante was born
in blank you might imagine that if bert
is going to do a good job with its
self-supervised pre-training objective
it needs to be able to fill in that
blank and in order to fill in that blank
it needs to know where dante was born so
the model actually is kind of trained to
learn facts indirectly in this way and
indeed language models do seem to learn
a lot of facts this way
so to put it to the test as to how well
these language models pick up facts we
actually took t5 and applied the
following evaluation procedure
so after pre-training t5 on a
self-supervised objective much like the
fill in the blank objective i described
at the beginning of the talk and similar
to the objective that bert was trained
on where we take a chunk of input text
and we randomly remove words and replace
them with math tokens and train the
model to fill in the missing fill in the
blanks basically
we then evaluate the model basically by
training it to predict the answers to
questions without any additional context
and then testing it to answer unseen
questions so for example
we might ask it when was franklin d
roosevelt born and we evaluate the model
on how well it predicts the year 1882
which was franklin d roosevelt's birth
year
so
since we're only feeding the model this
question we're not feeding the model any
additional context and giving it we're
not giving it any access to any external
information whatsoever you might imagine
that the only way that the model can
predict the year 1882 correctly was if
it saw
the fact that franklin d roosevelt was
born in 1882 at some point during its
pre-training
and so
you might imagine that if the model was
trained to fill in the blanks in the
sentence franklin president franklin
blank born blank january 1882 maybe has
somehow internalized this knowledge
and so this kind of gives us a test of a
kind of a real world test of how much
knowledge a language model internalizes
and it also allows us to use standard
kind of off-the-shelf question answering
benchmarks
most of the time at least before
we wrote this paper when people would
evaluate language models on these
benchmarks they would allow the model to
access external information either by
feeding in some context that actually
contain the answer like in reading
comprehension or by providing a way for
the model to look up information in an
external collection of knowledge like
maybe you could think of it like
searching with the pdf and finding an
article and extracting a paragraph and
extracting the answer from the paragraph
so that's what people call open domain
question answering we are calling this
closed book question answering because
you're not allowed to open the book when
you're when you're answering the
question
so if we evaluate a various sizes of t5
on this task you can see that we
actually don't do as well as the open
domain
state-of-the-art on on any of these
three kind of standard open domain
question answering benchmarks
we do a bit worse in every case but
notably
you can see that as the model size
increases kind of as we go from light
blue to dark blue the model's
performance reliably gets better which
suggests that larger models
tend to internalize more knowledge than
smaller models
and just to be more specific you know t5
base is a model with a few hundred
million parameters t5x excel is a model
with
about around 11 billion parameters so
we're varying the size by
two orders of magnitude or so and you
can see that uh models do tend to
apparently internalize more knowledge as
they get larger and larger
so we thought this was interesting right
because we're doing kind of respectably
on these benchmarks compared to an open
domain state of the art despite the fact
that we have no access to external
knowledge or information whatsoever so
we really you know in order to do well
on this task t5 really needs to have
learned all of this information during
its pre-training
but we wanted to know if we could do a
little better
so we took an idea from a paper that
came out around the same time called
realm which stands for retrieval
augmented language model pre-training
and the idea behind the idea here is
that rather than just picking words
randomly to mask out you intentionally
remove words that kind of look like
entities
so maybe in this example sentence here
we removed the person's name anna santos
aramburo
and the hope is that by intentionally
masking out
kind of phrases that correspond to
entities the model will learn more
information about entities specifically
so if we take one of the models that i
just showed on the last screen and we do
additional pre-training with the same
mass language modeling objective you can
see that the performance that's shown in
orange here you can see the performance
doesn't increase much it kind of just
stays flat but if we do the salient span
masking pre-training where we
intentionally mask out you know chunks
of the input that correspond to entities
you can see that the performance on
these downstream uh
question answering benchmarks just tends
to increase and increase
so if we take the largest model and we
do some additional saline spam masking
pre-training you can see what happens in
the purple bar here and you can see that
we actually go a significant way towards
closing the gap with the open domain
state of the art
by by doing this additional pre-training
step and actually on web questions
ultimately beat the state of the art by
just a small amount
which is quite exciting right because it
means that this model this model that
this very large model actually has
enough information in it that it can
get better performance than a model that
can actually look up the information so
it's better at looking up information in
its parameters than a model that's
looking up information let's say like on
the internet or on wikipedia
and just to kind of make the results a
little more optimistic we'll just
quickly point out that
the way that these models are typically
evaluated is by measuring whether their
output matches after some normalization
one of the annotated answers for that
particular question so you can see here
this uh
in this first example the model's being
asked what the ghost of christmas
presents sprinkles from his torch the
possible answers are either little
warmth or warmth and our model predicted
confetti that's clearly wrong but there
are actually cases where the model can
output kind of a a synonym or a
paraphrase or you know some text that
means the same thing as the true target
but it gets counted as incorrect because
it doesn't actually match the target so
for example if the correct target is
kate mold grew but the model predicted
catherine kiernan maria mulgrew it gets
counted as incorrect even though those
actually do refer to the same people
and so if we went through and looked at
some of the
examples that were being counted
incorrectly and categorize them
according to these different categories
if we
basically count the things that it
actually got correct as correct and
remove the things that there was no way
for it to get correct then our score
actually goes up significantly and
actually outperforms the open domain
state of the art
open domain question answering models
don't suffer from quite the same issue
because most of the time that ground
truth annotated answers are annotated
according to the text that the model is
actually going to be extracting the
answer from
so
all this is to say that it really does
seem to be the case that language models
learn lots of useful world knowledge
through their
pre-training
and it's not too hard to get the model
to retrieve that knowledge and answer
questions correctly
so
a natural question to ask after that is
okay so the model
picks up lots of kind of
what we might call like trivia knowledge
like general knowledge that you might
that applies to well-known entities and
so on and another question to ask is
does the model also pick up a lot of not
so general knowledge that is just kind
of very very specific knowledge that
maybe doesn't appear that many times on
the internet most people in fact almost
no one would actually know this but the
model never the less memorized it
and so
we
wrote a follow-up paper that attempted
to answer this question by studying the
gpg2 model released by openai
and our basic goal was to see whether
feeding a particular text prefix into
the model could make the model
output something that was clearly
memorized you know that clearly only
appeared a few times on the internet and
was not general purpose knowledge like
franklin d roosevelt's birthday
and i wouldn't be talking about this if
it wasn't true that the model actually
does memorize stuff so here's one
example where feeding in a kind of
nonsensical prefix caused the model to
output the
name email address phone number and fax
number of a real person
and this particular chunk of text only
appears on one website on the internet
so how did we find these examples of
memorized text
i won't go through this in a ton of
detail but i'll just describe what we
did at a high level
we fed the model with various prefixes
these prefixes were either sampled
randomly from the internet or were
generations from the model itself then
in order to identify
completions that seemed likely to be
memorized we compared the
perplexity or the likelihood assigned by
the model to its own generations to the
score assigned by a different model
right so if you imagine i have two
models
and these models were trained on disk
joint training data
a model that is outputting something
that it has memorized might assign a lot
higher likelihood to that memorized data
than a model that wasn't trained on that
data at all and so we compared these
likelihoods or these complex these
perplexities
across
different models in order to hopefully
find
text output by a given model that it
thinks is
unrealistically and unusually likely
that it really shouldn't seem
as so likely
and then according to this score we
chose some examples that we thought were
particularly likely to be memorized
performed at internet search if we found
it somewhere on the internet we asked
gpt2's authors if it was in the training
set or not and that's how we ended up
identifying a bunch of text uh that gpt2
output that appeared in the training set
and so just to give a more concrete
example
of what this kind of comparison of
scores method might do
you can see
on the x-axis here the perplexity
assigned by gpg2 to a particular example
where a lower perplexity means that the
model thinks that it's more likely
and the entropy assigned to a particular
example by zlib where a higher entropy
means that zlib thinks it's it's less
likely and so you can see there are
these examples here that are kind of on
the
top left of the graph
are examples where gpt2 thinks it's a
very very very likely and zlib thinks
it's very very unlikely
and so if we kind of look at a bunch of
those examples
that have been highlighted in
blue and red you can see that a bunch of
them actually did end up being memorized
training data from a gb2's training data
set so this is a pretty effective way of
identifying
memorized content
and one other result that i'll highlight
from this paper is that kind of by
coincidence there was a
one document that we found on the
internet that just had a list of a ton
of urls
and we knew that this document was in
gb2's training data we confirmed it with
the authors
and
it just happened that a bunch of these
urls were duplicated in this document
and
and the amount that they were duplicated
varied from url to url so you can see on
this table here we're showing one url
that was
in this document eight times and one url
that was in this document 359 times and
we know that gpt2 was trained on this
data
and fortunately the authors of gpt2
trained models of varying sizes all the
way up to one and a half billion
parameters the xl model
and what we found was that the
likelihood that a model memorized a
particular url
was much higher
when it didn't appear as many times for
the largest model i think i might have
said that in a slightly confusing way so
the the much less confusing way to say
that is that larger models need to see
examples fewer times in order to
memorize them is what the what this
particular result this kind of
accidental result suggests
so just as with models picking up world
knowledge better as they get larger
models also seem to memorize
not so worldly knowledge just kind of
specific facts in the training data
specific data in the training data a
specific text from the training data as
they get larger it's kind of easy to
cause this memorization to happen
which is
uh interesting
maybe good may be bad
we can discuss that later
so hopefully that convinces you that
language models learn facts uh i'll stop
there again to see if there are any
questions about anything so far
i think there's a question in the
chat um when correcting the evaluation
of t5 what do you mean by unanswerable
prompts
yeah thanks for that question i i didn't
uh
i didn't cover that just in the interest
of time but i'll mention it now since i
i know it was confusing so
if a model isn't allowed to look up
information on the internet or at least
look up information in the fixed
knowledge source and i ask the model
something like who is the president of
the united states there's no way to
answer that question without providing
it with additional information for
example what year it is or just
providing it with a fixed knowledge base
to look up the information
so
those questions aren't really a problem
for these open domain question answering
data sets because all of these data sets
are shipped with a fixed knowledge
source that is basically a snapshot in
time
but since our model
its knowledge sources whatever its
pre-training data is if you ask it what
the president is it thinks that the
president is whoever was the president
at the time that it was pre-trained um
and so we can get those questions wrong
uh
more broadly you can just think of them
as ambiguous questions uh and and
they're not answerable by a model that
doesn't have access to external fixed
knowledge
do we want to answer a question
yeah um
just to follow if i'm answering is it
is that accomplished just by hand
labeling uh which questions are
unanswerable and um you know the
which answers count as uh you know
phrase mismatches yeah or is there some
way to do it yeah we did not attempt to
do it automatically we actually the
other first author and i sat down and
just you know spent today doing it and
we actually released our annotation so
you can go and see if you agree or
disagree with us
thank you
um one more question in the chat do
these models just memorize or can they
also learn rules such as basic or
rhythmic
such as your in all math equations
yeah that's a good question i think the
i probably will wait to answer that
question until um
after the next section because i think
the next section goes some way to
addressing that question
uh this might not be like a meaningful
question to ask but is it kind of
possible to see or to like think about
how
um
you said that the knowledge is kind of
stored in the parameters is there
i guess like how um you know is there
like a structure or some way that you
know different parts of the model or
different you know layers or whatever
store different pieces of information
yeah there has been some follow-up work
that has attempted to either
identify whether knowledge is localized
in a model or whether it's possible to
more intentionally localize knowledge in
a model um that's not work that i've
done or that i've looked into a ton of
detail but but i'm happy to be i'd have
to i'd be happy to send pointers after
the talk if you follow up with me
thank you yep
cool uh maybe
an interesting time i'll move on to the
next section but then i'll be happy to
take questions after the talk
so
hopefully you're now convinced that
this simple self-supervised approach
causes models to learn things about
language it causes models to learn
things about the world
now we'll try to see if it causes models
to learn actually how to perform useful
tasks
and so
this the setup that we use to answer
this question is somewhat different from
the transfer learning setup that we've
mostly been using so far
in
in this particular setup which we call
zero shot evaluation
we still pre-train the model with an
unsupervised objective where we and in
this case
however that unsupervised pre-training
objective is now somewhat different so
rather than for example masking out
words
we do something a little more specific
that looks kind of more like what people
think of when they say language modeling
which is just that we train the model to
predict what comes next so we feed in
some text this is just a continuous
block of text and then we train the
model to predict the following text so
it's it's kind of just being trained for
next step prediction it's what people
usually mean when they just say language
modeling without qualification
and the question will be if we train the
model in this way can we
prompt the model in a particular way
that elicits a correct response to for
some particular task so here i'm showing
a natural language inference task
where the model is being asked whether
it's possible to infer a particular
statement from another statement so this
is a classic natural language processing
task and it's being converted to a
question answering format so if if you
imagine that somewhere on the internet
someone asked this model if someone
wrote down a question and the answer
after the question which is not
unreasonable to expect
and the model was pre-trained on that
data
then maybe the model starts to learn
how to answer questions and so if you
ask it a question like this maybe it
will predict the word yes as more likely
than the word no and in doing so it's
essentially labeling this example from
natural language inference it's labeling
that the banker contacted the professors
and the athlete
allows one to infer that the banker
contacted the professors okay so
by doing this language model
pre-training this next step prediction
pre-training we can cast tasks in a
particular format that allows us to
evaluate things
evaluate tasks without doing any
additional training right so i'm just
feeding in this new context to the model
and seeing if it predicts the answer
correctly
and you can cast just like with the
text-to-text format from t5 you can cast
lots of tasks this way right and so
actually question answering tasks are a
natural fit for this because question
answering tasks consist of a question
followed by an answer so to give an
example if we take trivia qa which we
used in the paper i described a couple a
little bit ago and we just feed a large
language model questions from trivia qa
and measure how often it predicts the
answer correctly
it actually gets the answer correctly a
pretty significant proportion of the
time so these are results from language
models or few shot learners also known
as the gbt3 paper and one of the major
characteristics of this paper was trying
models of varying sizes up to an
extremely large model with 175 billion
parameters and sure enough just like we
saw with the closed book question
answering results with t5 the
performance of the model tends to
increase as the size of the model grows
the difference here is that there was no
adaptation step for gpg3 you know after
doing language model pre-training the
model was just fed questions and
and it was evaluated on whether it
answered the questions correctly and it
does uh quite well in tribute qa
specifically it also does quite well on
lots of other tasks uh in some cases on
natural language inference like i just
described on things like paraphrase
identification so do these two sentences
mean the same thing sentiment analysis
you know is this movie review positive
or negative really on a huge variety of
tasks so the conjecture therefore was
that this unsupervised language model
pre-training kind of produces a model
that is effectively a multi-task model
it can perform lots and lots of tasks
reasonably well
and i think when a lot of people
interpreted these results they sort of
thought of
gbt3 as doing this kind of
by magic because it is becoming kind of
like a more and more powerful model and
so it just knows more and more and more
things um
and that it it kind of achieves this
magic through
unsupervised pre-training
but
i've
started to try to
push a different perspective a little
bit which is that actually it's pretty
likely that gpt-3 saw examples saw what
we would probably call labeled examples
from lots of tasks during its
pre-training kind of by accident so on
this slide i'm showing some text that
appears on websites on the internet
these examples actually all come from a
data set called c4 we couldn't perform
this analysis on gbg3's data set because
it wasn't publicly released
but at any rate this is text that
appeared on websites on the internet at
some point in time gpt3 was trained on
text from the internet so it's not
unreasonable to think that gbt3 might
have been trained on text that looks
something like this
so for example
you can see that there's text on the
internet that looks a lot like closed
book question answering like who is
frank sinatra an american singer actor
and producer
paraphrase identification someone's
asking do these sentences mean the same
and then provides the two sentences
natural language inference summarization
and so on uh these are all
these are kind of classic nlp tasks that
gpt3 was evaluated on but this is data
that appears on the internet so it seems
not unlikely that gbt3 was actually kind
of accidentally trained
in a kind of supervised multitask way
and that might go some ways towards
explaining why the model can perform
lots of lots of tasks after unsupervised
pre-training but now the question
becomes
if i just train a model with multi-task
supervised training intentionally
will i get a model that can perform new
tasks that it hasn't been trained on or
that i don't think it's been trained on
it generalized to new tasks kind of in
the meta learning sense uh that that are
unlikely to be in in the trading data or
at least uh
yeah i'll leave it at that
um and to try to answer this question we
introduced a new model called t0 and the
basic idea here
is just that we're going to take a model
that was trained with unsupervised
pre-training
and then we're going to train it
explicitly via supervised multitask
learning and then we're going to
evaluate it in terms of its zero shot
performance on new tasks that weren't
included in the intentional multitask
supervised training step
and just like with gbt3 with this zero
shot evaluation paradigm we're going to
cast all of these tasks as into what we
would call like a prompted form so this
is a way of taking an example from the
data set and mapping it to some input
and output text that kind of describe
what you want the model to do in human
readable text
so for example for paraphrase
identification we feed in the two
questions
in quotes and then we say pick one these
questions are duplicates or not
duplicates so if i presented you a human
with this text and you you know spoke
english and knew
uh how to identify paraphrases you would
be able to tell me that those two
sentences are not duplicates and so we
do the same thing with t0 we map things
into this format and we train t0 to
output the the corresponding text
and then finally after doing this
multi-task pre-training or intermediate
training step i should say we evaluate
its performance on new tasks that
weren't included in the multitask
training step
and just to give you a sense of the
tasks that we included here are kind of
a
shown in yellow or the tasks that we
actually did did pre-training on uh for
the for
and and yellow or blue i should say and
then in green are tasks and data sets
that we did not uh train the model on at
all so those are the the data sets and
tasks that we're going to be evaluating
the model's performance on
you can see that we actually we tried to
get a pretty diverse collection of tasks
during pre-training with the thought
that that might
improve the model's zero shot pass
generalization abilities
so the next thing we had to do was
actually take data from all of these
data sets and come up with templates
that allow us to map them into a
prompted form so for example going back
to the paraphrasing example
we
you can see in green here we write a
template that says take the first
question and the second question and
then write the text pick one these
questions are duplicates or not
duplicates and then we
measure whether the model assigns a
higher likelihood to duplicates or not
duplicates
and you can see that we can apply this
kind of templating procedure to a pretty
wide variety of tasks and data sets uh
we actually kind of crowdsourced this
procedure found a bunch of people who
wanted to contribute and ended up
writing
over almost 2 000 templates for almost
200 data sets
so now the question is does t0
outperform gpg3 in terms of zero shot
pass generalization
so we looked specifically at these four
tasks shown on the screen here that's
natural language inference story
completion co-reference and word
sensitive disambiguation
and uh you there are
two models shown in green one model is
basically you could think of as just the
base t5 model and then t0 which is the
model that had this additional
intermediate multi-task training step
and first of all you can see that doing
the multi-task training greatly improves
the model's zero shot attached
generalization would suggest that
training on this kind of tasky data does
improve the model's ability to perform
new tasks
and then interestingly we also
outperform gpg3 on the law or match the
performance on a lot of these tasks and
that includes the largest gpt3 model
with 175 billion parameters which is 16
times larger than t0
so it does seem that actually seeing
this
the supervised multitask data
allows the model to perform
better
generalization to new tasks in many
cases despite being much smaller so it
might be a more efficient way to induce
this zero shot generalization behavior
and it suggests to me at least that it's
possible that one of the reasons that
gpt3 does zero shot generalization at
all is because it actually saw a decent
amount of multitask
supervised multitask training data
during pre-training
we also evaluated the uh the t0 model on
this new benchmark called big bench i
won't go into a lot of detail on these
results except to say that again teaser
outperformed kind of standard language
models that were over six times larger
so just to recap what i've described so
far i've sort of argued that language
modeling effectively results in a
meta-learned model
maybe because language modeling seems to
teach models about language also about
world knowledge and also probably
teaches the model explicit multi-task
supervision
for for
for different tasks
and
the other thing that i've kind of
sneak snuck into this discussion is is
what happens when we make language
models larger
and it seems that
language larger language models actually
tend to learn more world knowledge right
because the larger variants of t5
performed better on the closed book
question answering task
they also seem to learn more esoteric
facts right like gpt2 the larger variant
of gpt2 seem to have memorized more data
than the smaller variants
and
it also seems that as models get larger
they learn to do more tasks or at least
they perform better
in terms of their zero shot performance
on on on downstream tasks
and what i'd like to highlight is that
world knowledge like the the knowledge
that the model picks up and the esoteric
facts that the model learns and the the
task that a model is actually trained on
these are mostly a function of the data
that the model is trained on right like
if i just take a randomly initialized
language model it's very unlikely that
the model is going to be able to tell me
franklin d roosevelt's birth date
without any training so
in some way at some point there was some
data that taught the model when franklin
d roosevelt's birthday was
or what someone's address and phone
number was or how to perform a
particular task
i say mostly because of course there are
other lots of other factors here but the
data certainly plays a very important
factor
uh so then i guess one question to ask
is
given that larger language models
perform these capabilities better how
large do language models need to be in
order to achieve kind of what we want
them to so just to give an example of
what we might want a language model to
be able to do
let's say that we actually want to use a
language model as a closed question
answer and we wanted to be able to
answer
questions about any
data in the wikidata knowledge graph
which is a very large knowledge graph
with lots of knowledge in it
this knowledge graph can be compressed
to a
file using bzip that is about 68
gigabytes
if you imagine that the best case uh
ability of a language model to store
knowledge in its parameters is about as
good as the compression abilities of
bzip
68 gigabytes corresponds to about 17
billion float 32 parameters so this is a
large model it's not gargantuan but it's
it's quite large so
and actually you might not expect a
language model to be able to compress
data as well as bzip i mean who knows
but at any rate you do actually need a
pretty large model in order to
[Music]
achieve certain goals whether you
actually want a language model that
knows all of this or not is sort of up
to you but at any rate
sometimes a scale seems somewhat
necessary
the the problem with scale is that in
order to train a large model
we often need to collect lots and lots
of data and it's very hard to audit that
data and so as people have figured out
pointed out rather
in for example the stochastic parrots
paper is that as we amplify the training
data as we make the training data bigger
and bigger to train these larger and
larger models
the training data can start to it's
harder and harder to make it so that the
training data doesn't have problematic
characteristics and the training data
becomes basically inaudible
which is potentially dangerous and
problematic for actual like real world
uses of these language models
and then the last point that i'll make
is that people are very excited about
large language models these days and
lots of people are training them and
releasing products based on them and
apis based on them
and most of these language models are as
far as we know very similar they're very
large transformer based language models
the main difference between these models
is really just the data that the model
is trained on and indeed as i described
earlier the data is probably a major
major factor in all of these useful
abilities that i've described that
language models
have like their knowledge of
facts their ability to perform tasks etc
but most of the time people pay
relatively little attention to what data
they're actually training their models
on so i guess this is all to say that
thinking more carefully about the data
that we're actually using to train these
large language models would probably be
pretty fruitful
so i know i'm just about out of time
i'll i'll end there
and i'd like to just mention uh i'm
trying to collect feedback on my talks
so if you have any if you think i talk
too fast or too slowly or covered too
much or too little or too technical or
not technical enough
please go to this url here and provide
me with anonymous feedback i greatly
would would value it
i'm happy to take a couple more
questions now
yeah i have one quick question i mean
thanks a lot for the talk it was just
super interesting stuff uh
get to kind of see how and how and when
these models just vacuum up knowledge or
when they don't from their data sets um
i'm curious you know you talked about
this phenomenon where knowledge ends up
embedded in the model's parameters this
is really interesting that this happens
but i'm curious if in practice or sort
of in future sort of work on modeling
that we do is this kind of
you know in your opinion kind of the
right way to get knowledge represented
in our models or when you see these
retrieval augmented models or sort of
semi-parametric models does this feel
like kind of
the more practical way to to you know
get this type of behavior or how do you
sort of contrast these two sort of
paradigms of like purely parametric and
having the knowledge explicitly
represented yeah so it's not clear to me
that um
that
purely parametric storage of knowledge
is the most efficient or exact way uh to
do it and certainly it has various
disadvantages like it's there's been a
lot of good and interesting work on this
but it's still not totally clear how to
selectively add update or remove
knowledge uh in this kind of like
distributed
uh
parameter representation
um
so so i i would definitely hesitate to
say that one approach was better or
worse um the main benefit of
building up knowledge in this way is
that it requires basically
no
uh
it
it it
basically requires that you collect a
lot of unlabeled text data and apply a
self-supervised objective to it
that
you know it's much less cost intensive
and labor intensive to do that than
build a knowledge graph or build a very
clean collection of knowledge
of course it also carries its own risks
and problems like i highlighted at the
end of the talk so i guess that's a very
long way of saying that i i definitely
could see both of these approaches um
having advantages and disadvantages in
certain situations
there's one question in the chat what do
you think will drive future progress in
language models small scale do you think
grounded language learning is promising
yeah so
you might have gathered from the end of
the talk that actually i think we will
a lot of progress can and should be made
with large language models by being more
careful about the data that we train
them on for example you can think of t0
as just being a lot more careful about
the data that we train the model on and
we ended up with a model that was 16
times smaller but worked about as well
or better than gbt3 in many cases you
know because we were intentionally doing
multi-task learning instead of doing it
by accident
grounded language learning
to me feels like definitely a way to
teach the model things that it would be
uh practical or impossible to provide
the model with via text alone um you
know it we we wouldn't necessarily
expect it to be efficient or easy for a
model to learn everything there is about
the world just by reading reading lots
of text um
i'm not saying that it's impossible it
might just be less efficient and so uh
and and you know and efficiency does
matter a lot so
that all that is to say that uh
i i
agree that grounded language learning
would be useful
but there are lots of other useful
things that we can do too
how can the multitask demonstrations be
extended to under under-resourced
languages on the web
yeah so we haven't so there have been
there's been a parallel line of work
measuring the kind of zero or few shot
transferability across languages that's
not something that we specifically have
studied although i i think it's super
interesting i think combining some of
these
approaches to doing uh zero shot task
generalization with approaches for doing
few or zero shot while language
generalization would be super
interesting
great um if i guess if there are no more
questions
we can end there i know people trying to
run and con i know you're extremely busy
so so thank you so much just for you
know sharing that power and change with
us so it was it was packed with packed
with knowledge
yeah and uh and i i usually say at the
end of the talk people can feel free to
email me too with any additional
follow-up questions and i did i dropped
the link to the talk feedback in the
chat in case anyone wants to do that
so but thanks again for having me it's
it's it's really fun
you